one of the best players in Major League
Baseball he's been red-hot for quite
some time now and that includes last
year I mean he was the MVP of the
National League and I've been wanting to
have mom the show for quite some time so
I'm glad that we can find some time
prior to his team taking on the Pirates
tonight Christian Yelich here on the
program how are you Christian
I'm doing great how are you I'm doing
great all right I'm gonna get right into
it here with you Christian uh what beer
were you slugging next to Bakhtiari last
week at the Bucs game
what was that one I forgot what I think
it was a honest it was a miller lite it
brought it to me
hmm so I want to say it was I want to
say it was another light but I was a
nervous to do it so I don't really
remember exactly what beer it was I was
more focused on keeping sure I got it
all the way down and not a not messing
up for all those people what how often
do you slam a beer like that Christian
oh it's definitely remember the last
time I've chugged a beer like that so
the bakhtiari obviously he put down
about four or five of them and he was
and then Aaron Aaron did his in the
first half and I saw a malt halftime and
they were telling me that I had to do
one and that I didn't really want to
because I hadn't played in a few days I
was like ah this might be this might be
a bad look hmm
and then they put the they put me on the
screen with the beer and then once that
happens it's no there's no now when you
said first half for Aaron you're talking
about the actual beer or they're talking
about the game what are you talking
about I guess I guess what's your
relationship with Aaron Rodgers
Christian just a little bit over the
last couple just really during the Bucs
playoff run through there I met him once
a long time ago if I don't you remember
it but just got to talking a little bit
at the Bucs games they they lined up
with a few off days so we're able to
just go there hang out and you know
cross paths a little bit okay do people
assume because you are balling out for
the Brewers right now that you're a
Packers fan I mean
is that an assumption that's being made
of you and mold yeah
the thing with Milwaukee and like just
sports in Wisconsin in general is like
the family you can't help but pull for
the other teams just because that's just
like the culture up there they're so
supportive of all the sports teams and
then once you're just immersed in it you
read that you really like click when the
Bucks started making their playoff run
like everyone was Bucks family you just
you can't help but be a fan of the other
teams and all the all the guys from the
other sports come out and support each
other they did that during our playoff
run so it's really cool thing to be a
part of that said you're from Thousand
Oaks which is now home to the Los
Angeles Rams practice facility and their
and their headquarters are you a fan of
any particular NFL team and I want to
get you any problems in in Packers
country but which team do or have I
think yeah I like I like player
I got there's no golf to the California
strong thing I've always liked Brady I
kind of just think it's amazing of how
you can be that good for that long and
like the dedication and preparation it
takes to play at that level for so long
and then obviously you know the Packer
fans and the Browns I mean you know you
really root for your friends and people
that you get to know throughout your
life so it's hard for me to say I have
one like diehard team because when I was
growing up in LA with and they have a
team so I wasn't born and raised on one
football team so I guess yes rootbeer
presence would be well when you're
talking about California strong you're
talking about what happened in Thousand
Oaks last year with the fires and the
shooting that took place there as well
right Christian is that what you're
referring to with golf yeah yeah yeah
and yeah Jarrod was kind enough to you
know take some time I was busy schedule
to right in the middle of their season
to kind of just help us out as much as
he could
it was great to see the support that
everybody gave us and we were able to
help a lot of people out and they
desperately needed it when was the first
time you realized you were pretty damn
good at baseball oh I don't know there's
like there was like different levels for
me where I was like all right I might
have a chance to play in college
probably my like sophomore year of high
school
then my junior senior year out of the
guy I might be able to get drafted we'll
see and then later in my senior years
like I I'm probably get drafted and then
it wasn't really until my first year in
big league camp which was 2013 the same
year I made my debut as a while I'm
actually probably gonna end up playing
big leagues and then it takes a while
for you to get adjusted to Major League
Baseball and for me you know there's
always been a process and obviously last
year is pretty awesome
it's just things that you know it's such
a humbling sport that you can't really
ever think you made it or can we contend
with where you're at yeah I mean it's it
is a great way to put in a humbling
sport I mean even those that are in
Cooperstown on average would get out
seven out of every ten times right I
mean and I'm just wondering if you've
been able to realize how it all clicked
last year what what brought you to
clicking last year and clicking as well
as you have so far this year Christian
after the all-star game you have the
whole all-star break and there's a
there's a good day off period like a day
before the second half starts and I got
back home and started watching some
stuff about like I wasn't feeling great
going in the all-star break just I got
the plate and all that stuff so I was
like I I want to kind of look at some
things try and get something get a plan
for the next day when we go in the
second half something I want to work on
in the cage before batting practice and
all that and look and decided to come
back into the cage that next day stand
like a little bit tossed right out the
first half of last year there's still
good happy and they'd all starting with
I thought there was room for improvement
and I decided to stand a little bit
taller and get a little bit more squared
up and it's something that I was able to
repeat and put my body in a good
position as many times as possible and
that's kind of just how it all started
how it started rolling Christian Yelich
the defending national league Most
Valuable Player from the Milwaukee
Brewers here on the Rich Eisen
showing obviously everything's working
out for you and Milwaukee you enjoy the
the scene there and people are enjoying
you and obviously we're enjoying a beer
at a Bucs game and etc do you ever think
about what might have been in Miami had
the team not been broken up including
your being traded away Christian yes
every now and then I still talk to some
of the guys about it and it's something
that we don't really want to just keep
like looking back in time lives like
just going back in the yearbooks but
there's definitely a lot of talent that
went through there it's sprinkled
throughout the league definitely see it
I mean some of the best players in
baseball right now we're on that team or
part at an organization before they were
traded off and went their separate ways
but it's just how it works I mean I
think we definitely had the pieces there
just didn't really all come together for
us for whatever reason and one that
happens in sports teams tend to move on
and the new ownership regime came in and
I mean I thought that was best but my
view is everything happens for a reason
they worked out great for myself it put
me in an unbelievable situation in
Milwaukee I really enjoyed that you know
you never guaranteed to go to a great
spot Antigua trade you don't know how
it's gonna work out you don't know what
the the city is gonna be like the teams
the guys on the team and I got really
fortunate that it couldn't work out any
better so do you so much has made
Christian about the popularity of the
sport nationally these days and keeping
it top of mind throughout the year
national pastime etc are so on and so
forth and look at young stars like
yourself do you have a philosophy on
making baseball fun or or getting out
there I appreciate a phone call into a
show like this for sure with obviously
being the one that I'm on do you have a
philosophy or a certain sense of
responsibility in that regard do you
think Christian to make it harder just
like get out there and get out there and
and and make it fun at the same time yes
yeah I think you always want to give
back to the game that gave you so much
and you never understand
you don't realize who you're impacting
or what impact you can have on
somebody's life I mean you don't know I
think it comes with the responsibility
in the position that you're into to
better the game and leave it in a better
place than what you found it in and it
started and changed as far as just guys
having more fun or being more expressive
or being more relatable it's a gradual
changes now it's not something that's
all going to happen it at one time or
everyone's just going to flip the switch
and the game's going to be different
than it's been for a long time but I
think you can gradually see it I think
the players want it Major League
Baseball wants it and it's headed in a
good direction well I guess they're
asking the major league leader in
homeruns right now would be a perfect
person ask what's your philosophy on
backflips like it don't like it
shouldn't happen not a big deal what
about I think there's a I think there's
a fine line it's like situational
awareness I don't really have a problem
with it most of them but you know that
it's it's hard to explain I mean I'm all
for that having fun looks bad I don't
care
most of the time but there's obviously
those outliers times where it's
definitely uh you know steps across the
line I think you could say sometimes but
you know my my philosophy though they've
just been win the game and if you do
something that helps your team win the
game or it's an exciting moment or why
not have fun why not show some emotion
you know the guys aren't all robots out
there they're not just you know living
the straight and narrow with no emotion
on their face or you know playing a game
in a big spot and if you do something
cool in front of 50,000 people and you
want to celebrate I mean by all means go
ahead and what's your philosophy
Christian Yelich on the shift what do
you like don't like not a big deal what
do you think I hate all towards yeah I
do man do I hate it I want to see you I
I don't want to see you bunt B just
because the the third-base line is open
for you I don't want it I I'm not gonna
I don't want to watch Christian Yelich
try and you know fashion is swing
different than just
the noise just to try and get a
seeing-eye base hit that's not what I'm
I want to see that's why teams do they
try and do it to eliminate slug so
whether I give you bunt against the
ships and you get a hit in their mind
that's a win for them where you didn't
there's no slug in that it's just like
basically like a walk or a single big
build they live with that and they want
you to try and change the swing so you
don't hit for power that's basically
that's mostly the premise of the shift
to take a hit to help win but a subtle
nuance that gets overlooked I think what
a casual fan is team to do it to prevent
slug and it's just all part of the game
that goes towards winning kind of see
that with the analytics revolution and
we're definitely one of those teams that
is you know deep into that and we try to
use it and I guess you can kind of see
that in our playoff fun by the way we
used our pitching staff and the way we
kind of tried to piece things together
to get ourselves into managing that's
the Dodger last year so yeah all that
stuff disappeared to kind of win give
him an edge and people definitely have
strong opinions about it last one for
you Christian Yelich before we send you
off into that Pittsburgh afternoon I'm
sure you saw what happened in Houston
last night where a young girl got hit
with a line drive and Albert Almora of
the Cubs was just mortified and it was
an awful moment I'm wondering what your
thought is on netting and putting it as
far towards the foul pole as necessary
what are your thoughts yeah I mean it's
terrible whenever that happened
unfortunately you do see that stuff a
lot over the course of the year and at
least we've got some netting now I mean
it used to be just where it was from
like the on deck on deck circled on deck
circle and even above the dugouts and
stuff were exposed and that's just
really really dangerous because I just
don't think people realize like how hard
the ball is coming off the bat how
quickly it gets on you and yeah
obviously safety is first and foremost
you never want to see anything like what
happened last night and you know I think
they should extend the netting as far as
and you
to make it safe and allow people to you
know come to a game enjoy it without
having to worry about something
potentially haven't happened to
themselves to their children or you know
one day you're going to a game and then
you know later that day you're going to
the hospital because something tragic
happens it's not good for anybody I get
for the game if I could for family so
obviously safety is first and foremost
do players have care I mean is it an
issue about wanting to communicate with
fans through a net honestly I'm
searching for anything here that might
look I mean yeah players don't have any
I think the majority of players would
probably want to see as much netting as
possible and for fans to be as safe as
possible you know I think some of the
pushback is that those are the best
seats people want to have a view but you
know I don't think the netting makes too
big of a difference as far as being able
to watch the game but I think players
are all in favor nobody wants to hit a
foul on the stands and see it hit
somebody or injure somebody that's just
tear it's terrible to see it's terrible
if you're the one that hit the ball like
Albert was last night I think almost
every major league player would be in
favor of as much netting as possible
well Christian thanks for the call man I
really love the way you play the game
I'm a fan and and I got a text during
this conversation from Alex Bregman
saying tell him L animal and the caballo
say Hawaii okay
yeah Bregman every time Bregman hits a
homer he lets me know that uh that he's
coming for me and yeah the first one
Sophos caballo and LNM all is Jake
Marisnick okay I don't know how they
gave themselves up nicknames well I've
never really asked but uh I guess you
have to have them on and have him you
know going in depth on his nickname
choice yeah it's just I don't know are
you allowed to call yourself the caballo
or el
that doesn't sound like you really
should be doing something like that I
don't know man I don't know what they
got going over there in Houston we
played them actually in a couple weeks
off the office see what's up with that
but they're do good friends it's a it's
fun banter during the season or okay if
someone if somebody goes deep there
they're talking trash in a group text oh
okay who do you modify or who else is on
this group text Christian Bregman okay
well the caballo hit a couple just a
couple nights ago so I guess he's he's
that object closer in your rear view
mirror let's put it that way
Christian thanks again for the call
hopefully we'll do this again real soon
absolutely you gotta that's Christian
Yelich for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app